bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on l'a vu
c'est le neuvième round des négociations
la dernière chance pour londres et
bruxelles de peut-être retrouver un
accord l'avant dernière je lirai parce
que si jusqu'au 31 décembre
on sait très bien que les négociations
peuvent durer jusqu'à cette date
fatidique
néanmoins l'état des négociations n'est
pas bon dans la mesure où il y a quand
même un joueur un pelé hier pour parler
la mode c'est boris johnson qui est
quelqu'un de totalement incalculable on
ne sait pas du tout sur quel pied danser
avec lui et j'ai très bien de la part du
patronat britannique loi du patronat
européen a demandé un accord mais le pen
n'est pas dit de côté il est unilatérale
nous avons affaire à un flambeur un
joueur on peut prendre tous les mots
qu'on veut pour désigner monsieur
quels sont les principaux points de
friction qui subsiste entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni en fait y
en a plein bien à plat il ya la pêche et
à l'irlande via l'action marché
intérieur si vous voulez y avait un
accord qui avait été signé et de cette
année 2020 devait être une année de
transition pour mettre en oeuvre cet
accord même si johnson a tout remis en
cause
donc aujourd'hui la question de fond
c'est pas simplement les accords
sectoriels
c'est de savoir si oui ou non la
grande-bretagne et respecte la parole
qu'elle a donnée est de savoir si oui ou
non on va tomber dans ce qu'on appelle
le no deal c'est à dire qu'il n'y aura
pas d'accord du tout et enlacés et l
encre alors les précédentes tentatives
de dialogue ont échoué on a du mal à
imaginer que contexte avec le contexte
sanitaire en plus que la situation se
débloque est-ce que selon vous elle
pourrait se débloquer peut-être d'ici
quelques mois
alors d'ici quelques mois il fit un
calendrier à je veux dire il ya une date
fatidique c'est le 31 décembre et puis
après
on verra non je pense pas qu'il faille
réfléchir dans ce mode de pensée je
pense très simplement qu'il y a une
volonté des deux côtés d'éviter le dos
dit mais il y avait je ne me répète un
des partenaires à savoir la grand
bretonne qui veut le beurre et l'argent
du beurre et bien en politique vous ne
pouvez pas avoir le beurre l'argent du
beurre et encore voir en relations
internationales
donc une fois de plus nous avons la
chance et peut-être pour les françaises
c'est véritablement un satisfecit
d'avoir un excellent négociateur du côté
de l'union européenne qui vit shell
barnier et de l'autre ' nous avons
quelqu'un qui ne n'est pas fair play
quand on est sur un terrain de football
il ya comment dirais-je deux équipes qui
s'affrontent chacune des deux équipes
veulent gagner mais il ya des règles et
s'il n'y a pas de règle pas tout
simplement rien carton jaune voire un
carton rouge c'est un peu la même chose
qui se passe est aujourd'hui l'attitude
de la grande bretagne vis-à-vis de
l'union européenne
c'est un carton jaune mais vraiment très
très très jaune foncé boire orange voire
enfoncer
on n'est pas loin du de la scission se
dire c'est clair mais c'est quand
quelqu'un ne respecte pas la parole
eh bien il doit savoir qu'il y aura un
retour de bâton
c'est ça qui se passe aujourd'hui on
peut l'éviter la condition d'éviter
justement gilbert casasus pour
comprendre vous parliez d'un odile
quelles seraient les conséquences pour
les milieux économiques en cas de nos
deals alors la grande-bretagne samedi et
enfonce une porte ouverte mais c'est
aussi un pays économiquement fort c'est
un pays qui a beaucoup de relations
économiques avec beaucoup
depuis l'union européenne notamment des
pays du nord c'est un pays maritime donc
il ya de très grands échanges maritimes
qui ont lieu il y a le cas du pétrole
l'écossais il ya des industries quand
même deux points qui à la city donc
voilà aussi des places financières de
toute première importance il y à des
universités reconnues comme cambridge et
oxford
d'ailleurs deux circonscriptions
électorales qui avaient voté contre la
politique qui ça mais pourquoi donc si
vous voulez la grande bretagne et
l'europe on tape tout à perdre
financièrement économiquement
commercialement dans nos villes mais
alors la question n'est pas de savoir si
c'est bien que tous les deux perdent
savoir qui est ce qui va perdre le plus
dans ce cas là celui qui va perdre le
plus de celle qu'il a perdue pu être
fabriqué mon but c'est la grande terre
gilbert casasus merci pour toutes ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur en études européennes